Both of these are true.
In class, it was shown that it is impossible
to produce a random sequence generator,
but if we have israndomsequence, I'm going to sketch out
how we could use that to generate a random sequence generator.
The first thing that we're going to do in our generaterandom function
is loop through all the sequences of length n.
Then for each sequence, we will run our israndomsequence test,
and if that israndomsequence test returns true, we will return the sequence.
We have now created a function that generates a random sequence,
which, as we've shown in class, is impossible.
Therefore, israndomsequence is impossible.
The second statement is also true.
This result is a bit counterintuitive.
The reason that this is a true statement
is that any true random number generator must eventually produce sequences
that fail israndomsequence.
Presumably, israndomsequence would fail, for example,
a sequence of 20 zeros, but a true random number generator
would eventually produce that sequence, and this further shows
the impossibility of having an israndomsequence procedure.